cet avenir de la filière nucléaire il
repose pour moi sur eux au fond 3 lignes
de force 3 conviction la première c'est
que notre avenir énergétique écologique
passe par le nucléaire
je suis conscient bien sûr que beaucoup
de nos concitoyens pensent que le
nucléaire polluent l'air et qu'il émet
des gaz à effet de serre l'image de la
fumée sortant du réacteur a la vie dure
or et vous le savez ici mieux
qu'ailleurs c'est tout le contraire
l'énergie nucléaire est l'énergie non
intermittentes qui émet le moins de co2
le giec le confirme la commission
européenne
le souligner plusieurs pays européens
comme la finlande la pologne la
république tchèque ou les pays bas se
sont engagés dans cette voie en étudiant
la réalisation de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires pour atteindre leurs
objectifs climatiques pour ne plus citer
puisqu'ils ont décidé de quitter l'union
européenne nos amis britanniques qui
néanmoins l'on choisit en nous donnant
beaucoup de travail oui l'énergie
nucléaire quand il s'agit de produire de
l'électricité non intermittente tout en
respectant et en protégeant le climat
est pertinente
pourvu que l'on progresse sur la gestion
des déchets sur la sûreté et je vous
sais là aussi pleinement mobilisé
l'énergie nucléaire est une énergie
décarbonée une énergie sûre